it's a magic square a magic square is an
array of numbers which you put in
columns and rows so in this case there
are four rows
and four columns
going up and down and you put a number
in each and the idea is to make sure
that the sum of all these numbers going
down
in each column is the same and the sum
of all numbers in each row is the same
and the diagonals and the other
diagonals so i want to draw in a
particular way
my favorite magic square and there are
bigger magic squares different famous
magic squares such as the one in dura's
painting but this i want to draw
showing you how it has extra special
magic properties extra special medley
properties that's a big pro that's a big
promise you're going to live up to that
well
you be the judge of that
so i'm going to draw a square
hopefully draw a square and put in
four columns four rows and i'm going to
write the numbers in a particular way
such as in modern calculators so i'm
going to write this as two
like that and as five like oops that's
meant to be square and then 18 and i'll
do 18 as a
two boxes
and then 51
and 82
this is going to take a time brady this
is a magic square let me show you why if
i add up all these numbers in each row
they come to the same total if i add up
all these numbers
that row that row that row and that row
each one comes to the same number or
this diagonal or that diagonal they add
up or this little square in here they
all add up to the same number which is
one seven
six i'm writing it in normal curly
numbers you'll see the reason why in a
minute this 28 plus 15 plus 52 plus 81
is 176.
they're all the same number that's what
makes a magic square if i do a diagonal
58 plus 21 plus 15 plus 82 is equal to
176.
so this is quite remarkable that
somebody could dream up something 52
plus 15 plus 21 plus 88 is 176. 51 plus
15 plus 88 plus 22 is 176.
so whichever way you go diagonal across
down check it out for yourself it adds
up to 176 well let me show you what's
different about the way i've drawn this
if i now turn it upside down
i have 11 plus 22 plus 58 plus 85 which
is equal to 176. 82 plus 51 plus 25 plus
18 is 176.
and you go through 28 plus 15 plus 81
plus 52 is that 52 i can't write yes
that's 52. that's 176.
so whether you read it upside down
or backwards it's still the same but
there's even one more thing one more
thing which is absolutely beautiful i
can now get a mirror
and place it next to it and you will be
able to see the top row reads 28 82 55
and the next row is 15 51 88 and 22
these also add up to 176 so this is not
only a magic square which i can turn
upside down i can also look at it
reversed in a mirror and it's still 176.
so this is why this is more than just a
magic square it is a magic squared in
different ways in reversing and mirror
imaging and i find that incredible it
wouldn't have existed of course before
we had these modern ways of writing twos
and eights and fives
of course you can't do it that way round
that doesn't work that doesn't make any
sense at all so it's only up and down